deep in the remote jungles of Guyana far
from the coastal power grid where the
kaitor Falls meet a rainforest that
blankets the landscape a new generation
of Guyanese amerindians is seeing the
light
before solar power panels Adorn The
Village this underdeveloped region ran
on expensive diesel generators or no
power at all this
is the clamps or sleds when they didn't
have leads using the target to study at
night in the village of Cato an hour and
a half's flight from the capital of
Georgetown solar energy now Powers the
school's new computer lab the lights and
air conditioning that cools this
tropical climate it's quite comfortable
here in a remote area
so it's beautiful in terms of having our
solar energy and electricity up and
running
even thatched roof Hots are energized
Off the Grid it powered all of the
houses even government building like
schools the health center
um the village office
this renewable Renaissance was
previously possible but unaffordable
until now beneath the waters off the
Guyanese Coast lies a newly discovered
Bounty of oil enough to transform a
country with a poverty rate near 40
percent according to the World Bank to
an oil-rich Republic
now the nation's Newfound oil wealth is
funding an energy project that is
electrifying the rural landscape we are
pursuing a program to provide some 30
000 solar home systems to communities
that are distant and far removed from
the National Grid well Guyana is just
beginning to export oil to the world
president Irfan Ali wants to replace
carbon-based fuels at home with
renewable energy with a goal of cutting
the cost of power in half we have a very
oil grid system
or power is driven by fossil fuel the
demand for power has grown
exponentiously so we're investing in
solar Hydro wind
and natural gas as part of our Energy
Mix the nation's energy planners are
harnessing the rain forest rivers to
power hydro plants like this one near
Cato even in the capital of Georgetown
where guyana's oil boom is being felt
the most solar power is transforming the
landscape and the power grid if that
boom can continue experts say the fossil
fuel Bounty off the Guyanese Coast has
the potential to provide clean energy to
the country's remotest regions and lift
the fortunes of the Next Generation John
hendron Al Jazeera Georgetown Guyana